hey it's going on I'm Brian Ronald's hey
guys it's kevin dean i'm here to
downtown independent so i have a good
idea next friday june first if you
aren't doing anything then I really want
you to come to our premier its first of
all it really state-of-the-art awesome
theater that not many people have been
to or know about downtown called the
downtown Indy hold on a second you did I
know you guys are all busy on fridays
there's lots going on there's there's
reality shows to watch there's your TiVo
of the week to play back but I just want
to say we're gonna have a great this is
my life right here this is this is
quality I think whatever I've started
you can give you a starting price give
me a start you don't have to start from
you start from the film and how we just
had a camera and I'm really excited to
see the world premiere of goodbye
promise now with the killa cam it
because i haven't seen it yet i've been
waiting what is it to three years for
the world premiere of hit by promise we
kind of kept it under wraps to this
point to this point only only 30 people
have seen the film and now work now
we're going to begin
while we're you and hopefully many
others will have the opportunity to see
it a little parks there no this is the
film we're going to be premiering so
it's kind of a labor of love we shouted
about three years ago and it's hard to
believe that a film that we shot for
nothing with a seven hundred dollar
camera it was born out of the idea of
just overcoming any challenges or
obstacles in front of you based on a
crumble
started shooting anyway and we sort of
made a story happen while we were
shooting
and it was developing as we were
shooting for you just we're just going
to grab the camera you're not going to
have necessarily any other resources
you're not going to have any money and
it's hard to believe that that thing
that we thought we had wasted time on is
now seeing the light of day we'll have a
red carpet will have photographers you
can get an IMDb photo that everybody
wants that red car mashhad your IMDb
this is the off tonight june four excuse
me it's not tonight it's just to first a
guy gives himself seven years to go to
Los Angeles to become an actor if he
doesn't make it he's quitting so we're
at now 16 years 356 days later something
like that
what's he gonna do come find out okay
I'll be here I'm join me we're going to
see what everyone's been talking about
goodbye promise when you say combined
your dreams
we're proud to show it to you so June
first countdown 87 p.m. I would love to
meet you there so June first 2012
downtown independent 25 on South Main
Street 9
a great night we're happy that were so
indiscreet it for a week at the time
independent and we're really hoping
you'll come out and you'll join us see
you there